in a head-on collision enormous forces
are brought to bear on both passengers
and cargo that's especially the case
when two different sized cars collide as
in this crash test from 2008 the small
Fiat has no chance against the big Audi
test engineer and alia Scott sec says
vehicles were always tested against each
other in the past that meant it was
difficult to pinpoint the weaknesses of
each car like whoa not so a new test
procedure is being introduced to analyze
how a vehicle's front section behaves in
a head-on collision the car will collide
with a basic chassis attached to an
aluminum block that crumples on impact
the damage done to the block can then be
measured the idea is to optimize the
front sections of all vehicles so they
act like a protective shield absorbing
the energy of the impact and protecting
the other car too
you know medical kit tests like these
are already being done in the US he says
and European cars haven't scored well in
them Japanese cars fare better the front
sections of their vehicles are designed
so they perform better in crash
situations European automakers are only
now starting to improve their cars the
Japanese were much quicker of the Martha
on phone in default efrain sofa by son d
upon acenta partly to Guillen two weeks
the German automobile club tested three
lower mid-range vehicles and achieved
similar test results they show important
differences in the design of the car's
front sections with varying impact on
the other party involved in the crash
the VW Golf only has a rigid front
longitudinal member that bores into the
other vehicle during impact the renault
megane distributes the force is better
but it's still not optimal
the Honda Civic has a well-designed
crumple zone here the force of impact is
spread over a wide area
you
the Cecilia this is the damage left by
the VW Golf this is where the front
longitudinal section plowed in its left
a huge hole that's why the block has
been gashed so badly the longitudinal
member is like a stiletto heel when you
stand on someone's foot the entire
weight is concentrated on that one point
creating much greater injury than a
sports shoe for example where the weight
is distributed thereby reducing the pain
it's too much ground to Andrew dear d
croft beso fatale this is it sudo this
is the damage left by the Honda Civic
you can see the block has been deformed
over a wide area but there are no major
holes and you can see that it hasn't
been crushed that badly so it could
still absorb a lot more energy all
flocked decisis adamu do I [ __ ]
Anarchy behind puzzle so Honda is
certainly on the right path with the
Civic this computer animation shows how
little the impact would be of two
vehicles like this that distribute the
force of impact through front cross bars
or involved in a head-on collision the
passenger compartment would remain
largely protected the weaknesses in the
crumple zones shown by the tests could
easily be improved with a few design
changes what's needed is for this test
to become part of the standard European
assessment process known as Euro NCAP
improving vehicle design and this way
could reduce the number of people killed
in accidents by up to seven percent
you